hallo leute heute machen wir nochmal
dasselbe was wir letztes mal schon
gemacht haben
ihr könnt dabei lernen wie bestimmte
gegenstände heißen welche artikel dieser
haben und dann werde ich euch fragen wen
oder was sehe ich
diese frage wird immer mit dem akkusativ
beantwortet wenn ihr euch das noch mal
genauer anschauen wollt dann könnt ihr
euch gerne die grammatik tabelle noch
einmal angucken und ja das war es auch
schon vor meiner seite und jetzt geht's
los
[Musik]
was ist das das ist ein schwamm
das ist der schwamm was sehe ich
ich sehe einen schwamm ich sehe den
schwamm
was mache ich mit einem schwamm schreibe
ich den boden
was ist das das ist ein pinsel
das ist der pinsel was sehe ich
ich sehe einen pinsel
ich sehe den pinsel was mache ich mit
einem pinsel streiche ich die wand was
ist das das ist ein besen
das ist der besen was sehe ich
ich sehe einen besen
ich sehe den besen was mache ich mit
einem besen fähige ich den boden was ist
das das ist ein hammer das ist der
hammer was sehe ich
ich sehe einen hammer ich sehe den
hammer was mache ich mit einem hammer
schlage ich nägel in die wand was ist
das das ist ein trichter das ist der
trichter was sehe ich
ich sehe einen trichter
ich sehe den trichter was mache ich mit
einem trichter gieße ich flüssigkeiten
in ein gefäß was ist das das ist ein
eimer das ist der eimer
was sehe ich ich sehe einen eimer ich
sehe den eimer was mache ich mit dem
eimer trage ich wasser was ist das das
ist ein spachtel das ist der sparte was
sehe ich
ich sehe einen spachtel ich sehe den
spachtel was mache ich mit einem
spachtel spachtel ich die löcher in der
wand zu was ist das das ist eine säge
das ist die säge was sehe ich
ich sehe eine säge ich sehe die säge was
mache ich mit einer säge säge ich
bretter oder holz was ist das das ist
eine kneifzange das ist die kneifzange
was sehe ich
ich sehe eine kneifzange ich sehe die
greifzange was mache ich mit einer
kneifzange ziehe ich die nägel aus der
wand was ist das das ist eine schraube
das ist die schraube was sehe ich
ich sehe eine schraube ich sehe die
schraube was mache ich schraube die
schraube in den schrank
was ist das das ist eine kette das ist
die kette was sehe ich
ich sehe eine kette
ich sehe die kette was mache ich mit
einer kette verschließe ich ein
gittertor was ist das das ist eine
mutter das ist die mutter was sehe ich
ich sehe eine mutter ich sehe die mutter
was mache ich drehe die mutter auf die
schraube was ist das das ist ein seil
das ist das seil was sehe ich
ich sehe ein seil
ich sehe das seil
was mache ich mit einem seil binde ich
gegenstände zusammen was ist das das ist
ein kehrblech das ist das kerbel ich was
sehe ich
ich sehe ein kehrblech ich sehe dass
kehrblech was mache ich mit dem care
blech trage ich schmutz in den mülleimer
ich hoffe ihr habt heute ein paar neue
wörter kennen lernen können und könnt
die frage wen oder was mit dem akkusativ
richtig beantworten
wenn nun noch weitere übungen zum
akkusativ haben wollt dann guckt gerne
auf unserer website ling vorbei die wird
hier unten nochmal eingeblendet und dann
verstehe ich mich jetzt und bis jetzt
nächste woche
[Musik]